with regard to these relations i've
heard you say quite a few times
relations are what are more fundamental
than the things itself
however to me as i'm having a difficult
time understanding that because to me a
relation presupposes things you can't
have a relation without having things to
have a relationship with unless you have
a relation between relations and then it
just keeps occurring infinitely
so
so how is one supposed to think of
relationships as fundamental
see even mathematically the way that i'm
thinking about this right now in model
theory you have a signature and then
relations
you need an arity functions like how
many are are going to be compared how
and then what is being compared i would
call the things
and then the relation needs those things
so help someone as confused as myself
understand what is meant by relations
are more fundamental than the things how
is it not presupposing things per se
yeah well it depends what we mean by
thing uh that's uh that's the subtlety
namely um if
we we're talking about quantum mechanics
so you're not talking about general
philosophical view of what so i i'm i'm
just saying what this interpretation
quantum mechanics requires us to do
all right
so uh in this individual quantum
mechanic the basic notions are
a system
systems
okay so i'm not
denying
it it's not an interpretation that
denies that we describe the world in
terms of systems okay if you want to
call the system a thing that's fine
those are things okay
this is a system
a pencil
okay
uh and then the relation of between
systems the things that happen between
systems in which a
pension has a color with respect to me
now why is a relation
uh because this this uh
this pen is is yellow
but what does it exactly mean that is
yellow yellow is not a property of the
pen by itself it's a property of the of
the pen that depends on the light that
bounces it the interaction with the
light and the the the peculiar uh
uh uh detectors in my eyes
uh which do not distinguish many
frequency but do distinguish some
frequency and so in terms of this
space of colors which is not outside in
the world is in my head
i call yellow
the way
this pencil interacts with the lighting
with me
so the being yellow of the of of the
pencil it's really something we only
understand if we bring into the picture
also the light and me and my brain and
the specific
three kind of detectors of light in my
eyes and so on and so forth good so this
this is an example of a relation to be
yellow is it's a relation sense
now
uh
why i said well depend what we mean by a
thing because if by a thing you mean a
an entity with a set of properties
okay this is a pen is here has zero
velocity is oriented up and down with a
with a point down
uh uh it's a certain thickness and
a certain mass a certain weight and uh
um and a certain position so on so forth
if by thing you mean this system with a
given set of properties that it has
then in relation quantum mechanics that
is wrong
because all these properties do not
belong to the
to the pen it belongs to the interaction
dependent whatever is outside
so in relation quantum mechanical
systems and and uh
and and and relation to the system
the properties of a system are all the
relations
but what we when we describe the world
we talk about properties uh we're not
not talking about the systems
we are saying well the moon is there a
position the position is relational with
respect to something else
uh all properties are relation in in
in quantum mechanics
so it's not that uh the only relations
in relation to quantum mechanics is that
uh
systems have no properties unless
uh relation
except relational properties are not
properties by themselves
having said yes one is tempted
uh and and many philosophers want to do
that and i have some sympathy for them
to make one step further
uh michelle bit bald is a good example
that uh his immediate reaction to a
racial quantum mechanic said well why
don't you take one step further
and say well for forget the system the
systems are just the
uh intersections so to say
between between relations
and you say this is hard for you to
conceive because it's a relation
required to think that's true
but uh you know
think of a network a net the net of a
fisherman
you can say it's a set of nodes
attached by the links
fine
but you can say it's just the links the
notes come just as a peculiar point
where
the links are attached to one another
so uh it's the same with a graph more
abstractly you can think of you can
define a graph in two ways you can say
it's a set of points
and then relation between the point i
mean there is a there is a link between
two points that's a relation or not
or you can say
it's a set of links
and then you say who's who is
which one of the link join to the other
so you can start from the point of start
from the links to to think of a graph
and so in that sense you might want to
uh just view the systems as just nodes
uh of of networks after all
uh we never see the moon we see its
properties
so our direct contact with the walls is
through
the properties of this object from which
we will construct the object
some philosophy might want to go
all that way uh i have some sympathy but
i don't think that the malaysian
interpretation of quantum mechanics uh
requires that version of the quantum
mechanics is in terms of systems
and relational properties between the
systems
no okay so you said there we can
describe a system or a system of that's
a graph let's say in terms of treating
the edges as primary or the vertices is
primary and then you can infer correct
okay so exactly is there a reason that
it seems like
because they're interchangeable you
could place emphasis on anyone why is it
that you're
choosing or why is it that it's better
to place emphasis on the relations
rather than the notes the edges
i think we can do both
i think i think both are doable as far
as quantum mechanics is uh
it's concerned
um
i
i think the key point is not their only
relations the key point is that
properties are only relational